i show how to go this so close ms do you
remember what it looks like it's the one
where it's from 0 to PI right so that's
why I'm just a monkey out so let's see
here mother it's the point but don't
forget that when you're drawing cos
inverse or sine inverse just like if you
were doing sign or cause the stationary
points are they should have horizontal
tenants right so here your time vertical
tangents about anyway that's a minor
point ok so there's why interest coz
inverse of x x equals a half where is
that well the domain of cos inverse and
sine inverse is domain domain that's the
domain minus 1 to 1 so he is minus 1
here's one okay there's that intercept
ok so then give us the line x equals a
half which is this vertical line you ok
happy and the X and Y axis so the actual
area of interest in you are it is
carefully is this one
okay so what you think about how to
solve this there are some problems
because normally we would find the area
under curve just by integrating right so
you would do this area from zero sorry
integral from zero to a half of this
graph which is causing vs event so great
okay except for the problem that we
don't know what the integral of cos
inverse is it's weird by the way you can
go go Wolfram Alpha and it's strange we
can differentiate cos inverse but we
cannot integrate it all right so
therefore you must have purchase area in
some other way okay now um when you're
thinking about areas and trying to get
sort of different approaches on it not
just using the regular or integral
that's standard okay there's lots of
different ways to skin a cat so I'm just
going to show you the first way that
came up to it's a common figure of
speech guys I'm just going to give you
the first one that came to me okay so
have a look with me remember this is
just regular cause or if you like just
like the sign but she did accept it
sideways okay so I want you looking at
um and rotate your head this way but
gets a look at it this way yeah how do i
work at that area well that area
consists of two parts firstly if I draw
a line across here like you see that
look at it sideways okay you got our
rectangle the end that tape was a fun we
can't deal with rectangles okay then you
at this little sort of whitby part here
okay very small how did you with that
what are you can come up with any
integral you like that will give you an
equivalent area anyone you like remember
Sonny cosigner read the same graph has
moved around so the first one that came
to my mind was well if you look again
tell your head like I'm starting from
here I'm going forward that looks to me
like Sian doesn't that look like site
like
this okay that's the beginning of
signing that comes down and keeps
gallery right so the question is what
part of sign is it ok well let's come
back this is cos inverse right so what's
this intercept in you pretty much this
is pi/2 right because the whole range is
on his part ok so halfway now if thats
plan to what's this value here this is
cos inverse of a half right because the
x values are half so therefore this
coordinate here should be cos inverse of
aha what's causing this of a hot one
angle do i need i take the cosine of it
that I get a half answer pi on three
right ok now one more question I'm
thinking about this like sign because
when I look at it sideways I'm like I
want the first part of sight and I'm
just trying to again how much so how
much what's the difference mean player 2
and player 3 16 right because pi r 2 is
just 3 PI on six and pine 3 is 3 PI on
62.6 is the difference so now when I
think about how do I like out this area
and I gave them names in my solution i
called this a and i called this be ok
you can stay area a is equivalent to the
integral from now I'm thinking in terms
of sine right just look look citing
that's just regular son it should 0.6 of
sine X with respect to X because I've
integrated horizontally not vertically
ok like this is you cannot do this for
me what's the integral of sine minus
cars
yeah it's easy to get mixed up so that's
that and then you evaluate it okay so
minus COS of pile and six that's minus
root amount to write minus three on two
yes and then you have to take away minus
cos of 0 minus causes your closet here
is 1 this is minus 1 okay so this area
that little sorry that little wicked bit
at the top is 1 minus returns to area n
okay now you work out the other area
it's a rectangle so what is its rid than
what is its height its width is harfa
unit and is height we already
established is PI on three so that
rectangle is planted so therefore sweet
bark pine 60 s 1 minus 20 this is a
really good it's a clever question
because it's trying to sort out you try
and think from the exam status point of
view let's try to sort out people who
just sort of blindly go in towards
intercourse because that's how we
usually work at the area under occur
right between the people who oh cool I
know how to integrate that and
differentiate and then the people who
look at it and they know they can't do
it but they're like I want and so this
is really a question of can you see this
is an area you actually very familiar
with okay so yeah